gar nicht begrüße Joachim Weber von der
Universität Bonn herzlich willkommen sie
als Sicherheitsexperte was sagen sie zu
dieser
zu harmlose man Räubergeschichte sagt
das ist schon eine sehr sehr brutale
Aktion die da stattgefunden hat gegen
eine elementare sicherheits- und und
Versorgungseinrichtung in der Tat das
ist wirklich nicht als eine abzutun
sondern es war ein Angriff da vor einem
halben Jahr auf die man muss was sagen
zentralste wichtigste sozusagen
kritikalste aller deutschen
Infrastrukturen weil schlicht wegen mehr
als die Hälfte der Energieversorgung
dieses Landes bislang daran gehangen
hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt ja schon nicht
mehr weil die Rosen gedrosselt hatten
aber aber dennoch von eminent wichtiger
Bedeutung und ähm ja ich erinnere mich
noch genau wie ich vom halben Jahr aus
diesem Sender hier rausgefunden auf dem
Rückweg hatte ich einen
Nachrichtenmagazin dran die fragten aber
das waren davor jetzt die Russen nicht
und wurde gesagt vorsichtig wissen wir
noch nicht gibt's manche Plausibilität
für aber so ganz überzeugend waren these
eben auch nie und ich glaube wir werden
noch man Überraschung erleben mit dieser
Geschichte eine Überraschung war ja
schon vor ein paar Wochen die Recherche
von amerikanischen Medien die zu mir
Ergebnis hatten es seien die USA gewesen
ja das war die These von Samuel Hirsch
der vor langer Zeit ein ein
star-journalist in den USA war und in
jüngeren Jahren mit seinen Recherche
Ergebnissen die auch das ein oder andere
mal etwas daneben gelegen hatte also
insofern ist das auch eine weitere These
die jetzt wieder legt zu sein scheint
also ich glaube wir können festhalten
die deutsche
Bundesanwaltschaft ist keine schwätze
Organisation nicht das ist nur wirklich
sozusagen das seriöseste was man sich
vorstellen kann und wenn da die
Ergebnisse so sind wir jetzt
ausgebreitet dann nehme ich das sehr
ernst als Ergebnis der bisherigen
Ermittlung aber die Geschichte mit einer
Segelyacht da hinzufahren und dann da
mal eben mit ein paar Tauchern
Sprengstoff anzubringen im Endeffekt
eine enorme Operation ist ja nötig um so
etwas auszuführen das ist schon eine
Operation deswegen glaube ich auch sich
an eine These dass das da irgendwie so
eine privatgruppe gewesen ist so nach
dem Motto wir wollen jetzt mal hier ein
Zeichen setzen und sprengender jetzt mal
eine Pipeline nicht also das sind sind
dicke Stahlrohre massiv mit Beton
ummantelt tief eingespült im Meeresgrund
ich glaube 60 80 Meter Wassertiefe das
können wirklich nur Profis und sie
müssen ja auch mehrere hundert Kilogramm
Sprengstoff anbringen um eben das dann
wirklich auch wirkungsvoll zu Explosion
zu kriegen und dann drei von vier
Stellen hat's ja geklappt an den
strengen also die professionell
gefälschten Pässe kommen dazu also das
sieht schon nach einer Operation einer
wirklich hervorragend ausgestatteten
Einrichtungen aus wie man sie
normalerweise doch wohl staatlichen
Geheimdiensten zu erkennen müsste in
welchem Licht steht die Ukraine jetzt da
weil ja schon immerhin jetzt ein
Verdacht auf sie fällt
es ist das müssen wir glaube ich betonen
wirklich nur ein Verdacht allenfalls ein
anfangs Verdacht mehr ist es zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht also wir müssen
und da haben Verteidigungsminister wie
Außenministerin vollkommen Recht wir
müssen uns jetzt vor Spekulationen hüten
es ist eine ernste nehmende Spur der
muss jetzt weiter mit großem Nachdruck
nachgegangen werden ich glaube
jedenfalls dass dieses Land dieses Volk
hier ein Anrecht darauf hat dass es hier
eine Aufklärung gibt soweit das möglich
sein wird damit wir in der Tat wissen
wer treibt hier welche Spiele in diesem
Krieg und am Ende dieses Krieges